hello everybody and welcome back and
okay
I'm okay yeah welcome back to Anna there
are now strange symbols on on the walls
door still locked I'm surprised those
eyes aren't in red okay someone
mentioned something about that it's
already taking the knife eating it up
ha then using it on my filth little cut
should be enough here we go oh oh that's
perfectly okay then
wait at least tell me your name
oh no oh no whoo what the hell was that
what was that supposed to be
Oh was that it
other pool is more red more sawdust
can't use these two together okay all
right
and then it's like hmm I don't know why
but the funnel got bigger that changed
it all no okay all right um so that's
there it's a deal what did the letter
say afterwards then I realized the truth
or something ah not sure
nope okay um maybe if I try everything I
have on me whoa
Oh whoo Oh Oh do it good night good
night
Oh for you oh no no oh lordy Lou oh no
no back deep Frick frack off
I can hear it stepping ooh
oh hey screw you create everything
what's the point what was the point of
that
hey don't like this game alright so um I
don't know what triggered that is like
I'll send boy maybe some more blood it
makes no sense they made a little sense
shut up okay now I'm back to being stuck
again
huh by maybe I could use the knife the
full knife on this padlock now can I use
these to get what is that one of the
notes say examine obsessed by security
he stretched out his arm and muttered
something he did blade at last year
fulfilled the right only when he had
seen his own blood pollute that limpid
water he realized he was drying to the
truth so I'm drying to the truth what is
the truth
it won't open
jammed semental concrete la nuova Linea
the tsuki echo compatibility / construir
green builder okay so now what I'm a
little confused because I'm exactly as
lost as I was before whoo-hoo that I
know whenever noises happening just
something happening hmm
I mean what's the deal with these
symbols gotta be a got to be a purpose
right free crescent moons 3d twirly
birds
whoa whoa where'd that come from
well huh oh they seem embossed pick up
use a knife to pry out the gems well
it's bigger knife how about the heated
knife
[Music]
okay all right oh why are they glowing
why are those ones angry why does that
guy have a Bible what was that
oh no oh no I don't want to progress oh
the eyes are going wait a minute hang on
maybe if I find more eyes are there
other paintings like this that I may
have missed man it's like I need to look
over everything like ten times it's so
easy to miss something
I know what the deal was with that like
shadow nothing in here I'm fine I'm fine
okay this is like done not a no starting
to reveal the truth okay if I use
another item on it I don't know the
dried leaves that Norway the sawdust did
ow
da Phil canteen dude cigarette letter
wink okay okay it's still the whole deal
or I guess I can't use this anymore okay
need something to fix it okay I don't
have anything to fix it do I one of
these two cans would work I don't know
fix it I don't have anything I don't
know what do you want from me what do
you want from me
looking everywhere at the moment you
find something uh what's there to find
what is this I know what this does what
the whole deal is of this thing open if
I use ritualistic knife on it maybe
because that makes sense oh shut up shut
up just shut up
[Music]
okay so we got the eyes the glowy glowy
eyes the sun's looking up at the eyes
the twin eyes but there's five eyes on
that door doesn't mean it's like telling
a story or something
I don't know I don't know I I don't know
there's something about they seem
embossed they look like blood drops ah
oh I'm sorry
[Music]
the desk was black the death was black
the hatred bronze the happiness golden a
solitude silvery yet the soul lie was
white ah doesn't work now it does not
work down
that's five eyes Oh bitter bordello I
can't use it
okay good good the eyes those are three
three eyes actually three eyes cuz
there's five eyes on this door right
wait hey hey I see I see I see
oh okay I five eyes are lit up can I
open that door now oh boy can't use it
problem that's the house I'm in why are
there so many dead things huh
[Music]
five eyes this high fiving on the door I
cannot use it maybe there's some order I
touched the eyebrows does not work now
tried to touch all these okay okay did I
really get a good look at this one
okay dad juji went down in this house I
know that cup falling down sound the can
getting knocked over wasn't wasn't
normal
it was part of its a scripted thing I
got a probably look around and find him
something that fell down oh just being
in this room for so long gives me the
willies is that scary maybe I could
light up the room a bit more cover this
candle please oh it's much better much
much better
it's almost warm and inviting yeah I got
written there it's not red guys are
still glowing
okay that's the normal that's normal
ambience
no it hasn't changed yep okay all right
it's almost like it's on a time thing
where I spend more time in here and it
makes sense but anyway I'm out of time
for now so thank you all so much for
watching and as always I'll see you in
the next part bye bye